for more I'm joined Now by rahima
Mahmoud UK director of the World uighur
Congress
you've seen that report uh finally Helen
Ann Smith able to get into those areas
where China has claimed the voluntary
re-education campaign is now over but
how concerned are you by our findings
that prisons are being expanded
thank you for having me and I'm very
grateful that
managed to do this report which we
already know that since uh you know this
Mass detention up to 3 million in
concentration camps and although Chinese
government have been often saying that
the these are completely closed down but
we know majority people not been uh you
know released we we only know that very
very minority released because of very
extreme poor psychological and the
physical conditions
um and this report just reflects
everything that we already know we know
people still are disappearing and uh
recently when I spoke to someone who
left the region and said they must
exercise Extreme Caution with each step
as if they are constantly on the verge
of stepping on a landmine yeah I mean
quite a description it's it's the same
as Helen and Smith saying you know
people couldn't even fill up their cars
without a security guard it is
extraordinary surveillance what about
the the prisons are you concerned that
this campaign against the uyghurs is
simply being transferred to mass
incarceration
absolutely oh absolutely we know uh
three million maybe more up until now we
don't see large number being released
even though the Chinese government have
been saying that they closed down this
this re-education facilities people
um graduated but I know many of my
friends uh they found out those
relatives who were taken into these
camps like a mama jam and the the number
of relatives
some like 14 members from extend family
received the long term some up to 20
years or a life imprisonment
for nothing there's no no crime
whatsoever they never committed any
crime at all
so it's the trouble is
China has said well the trouble is China
had previously denied that these camps
even existed
um what do you think can be done now to
help the weaker people
well
this is not just the camp we know the
forced labor products flooding into UK
and in many uh and as well as other
countries so government what they can do
is to get rid of all this Foster labor
products ban uh
request
high-tech surveillance companies and
also the UK Parliament already
recognized this as genocide the
government should also recognize it as
genocide and fulfill its responsibility
under the genocide convention and
Chinese government must be whole
accountable for its crimes this is a
crime against humanity and the genocide
we're going to leave it there thanks
very much indeed for joining us on Sky
News
attention